we're going to begin this hour with that
new series we call it facing facility
facing fertility rather where we explore
reproductive hurdles and giving voice to
the many women and men who suffer in
silence with infertility this morning
we're taking a look at the reality of
and vitro fertilization or IVF as it's
called as many as one in eight couples
struggle to conceive either due to
female or male infertility or in some
cases both Nikki Batiste talks with one
couple who are four years into their IVF
Journey
four years after they married Kristen
Connolly and Matt Smith were ready to
start a family but after a year of
trying to conceive without success the
then 34 year old Saul a fertility doctor
what did they find when they tested your
sperm all the most important factors
were pretty low or just didn't hit the
the normal range Matt had corrective
surgery but six months later they faced
another hurdle Kristen's egg count was
lower than expected I was actually
diagnosed with diminished ovarian
reserve so in 2020 they turned to in
vitro fertilization or IVF
the process required weeks of blood
draws ultrasounds and at-home hormone
shots to stimulate egg growth mature
eggs were then retrieved fertilized with
sperm in a lab and monitored to see if
they grew into embryos which the couple
then had genetically tested for
viability after four rounds of IVF
Kristen and Matt got their first viable
embryo and their first chance at
pregnancy but when the embryo was
transferred to Kristen's uterus it did
not implant how are you feeling
emotionally exhausted yeah it was like a
cycle you'd be worn out and you get
frustrated they decided to try an egg
donor it's such a big decision was it a
difficult one oh yeah you know what are
people going to say about if they find
out that we used a donor egg you know
I'm you know am I gonna relate with the
child because it's not my genetics with
donor eggs Kristen and Matt were finally
able to successfully transfer an embryo
but seven weeks later her I woke up in
the middle of the night and
knew I was miscarried
they're next to embryo transfers also
ended in miscarriages I think that was
a hard pill to swallow that
and I think I think we all sort why us
then we started questioning is this
should we be doing this in addition to
the emotional toll IVF can also take a
financial toll without insurance
coverage the average cost of one
medicated IVF cycle is about twelve
thousand dollars have you had to pay out
of pocket I would say at least
80 percent of what we've done has been
out of pocket Kristen and Matt are not
alone in their struggle it's been quite
a roller coaster so just no hold on last
August I found myself in a place I never
imagined I'd be facing my fourth IVF egg
retrieval I got six eggs this time it's
seven last time for the time before I
think five the first time my husband
Dean Simpson and I are desperately
trying to have a second child I've been
recording our journey so many people
struggle in Silence with infertility and
never talk about it we married at 36 but
delayed starting a family as I switched
jobs I was at a pivotal point in my
career and honestly I wanted to wait a
few years before we started trying to
have a family
the biggest regret of my life at age 38
we got pregnant quickly but then
suffered a miscarriage pregnant Again
Naturally we had our son Beau when I was
40. then at 41 another miscarriage at 42
we started IVF these are tanks where we
maintain frozen eggs and embryos in fact
your embryos are in this tank number 59
um wow it's making me emotional actually
Dr Eric Foreman is my reproductive
endocrinologist at Columbia University
Fertility Center in New York City a lot
of people
including myself maybe naively think IVF
is often successful and that just isn't
the reality yeah I think that's a
misperception even with our ability to
get multiple eggs and make multiple
embryos most of them cannot go on and
make a healthy baby and so most IVF
Cycles are not successful for women
under 35 the chance of having a baby
after a single IVF cycle is about 41
that drops to around 29 between the ages
of 35 and 37 and by age 42 it's down to
just nine percent I don't know yet if
it'll work if we'll be able to have
another child secondary infertility
is very difficult and you know shouldn't
be minimized for some women or couples
even more difficult because they really
want to give their child a sibling but I
think it's a different type of
experience at least you know knowing
that it's possible after four rounds of
IVF and genetic testing we had just one
viable embryo which my husband and I
transferred in November I've been
feeling a lot of fear leading up to this
day ten days later we just found out my
pregnancy test is positive
we're so grateful and in shock soon
after the tiny heartbeat we had been
hoping for
yeah so this will eventually hopefully
be the nursery Kristen and Matt say they
will keep trying
days before our interview they did
another Embryo transfer when you want to
be something so bad you know you'll do
whatever it takes
hope
this little embryo is the one
that's two
I think we are tired
Alex later they got some good news this
is good that's good that's good all
right
a positive pregnancy test their latest
transfer had worked
I just talked to Kristen and Matt last
night they are 13 weeks along and
Kristen is feeling pretty good I am 22
weeks pregnant and having gone through
this you worry every step of the way
that continues to go well they're just
three points that I want to make number
one as we mentioned in the piece IVs IVF
is extremely expensive we were able to
do it because I have good fertility
Insurance here at CBS but it was never
lost on me that so many people never
even have the luxury to try to I felt a
lot of guilt going through this because
we were going through it already having
a child and I would constantly think of
couples struggling with infertility
struggling through IVF for years and may
never have won at all and lastly and
this is really important for me I
pitched doing this for this facing
fertility series to Shauna Thomas our
executive producer after we had two
failed rounds and I said to her no one
talks about the fact that IVF does not
work more often than it does
statistically and you only hear the
success stories and so what I felt was
really important to make that point
obviously we're thrilled that it worked
we did not think it would work at that
point and also just a spark conversation
because so many people suffer in silence
with not just IVF struggles but
infertility across the board it's such
an important story I didn't know what
you just said that most no idea yeah in
many cases IVF doesn't work and I
learned a very hard painful lesson years
ago I would never do this now one of my
neighbors you know I was much younger
and we were talking about babies and I
said well what do you guys what are you
guys waiting for it's easy and she goes
actually Gail it's not it's not and that
was such a clawed knucklehead thing to
say and I think people say that in my
attempt to be cute and funny you just
never know what people are going through
that's why I think these stories are so
important I told you that Nikki that
when when Aaron and I decided to have a
baby I just thought well okay like this
is what happens and she had to school me
on that and I also told you how I learn
from you and others as I was on this
journey to becoming a father that so
many of my friends people that are in my
family are suffering in silence because
because they think that you won't
understand yeah and so many people
struggle even younger men and women and
like you said people don't talk about it
that's why we're here and there's
another point that we'll get into
tomorrow as a part of our Series where
we aren't educated about fertility and
infertility when we're younger and so it
can be a surprise sometimes when it's
too late well you're changing Nikki yeah
Nikki thank you so much for taking us
there honestly and it's a girl Gail
congratulations I'm excited with
whatever
add to the family I'm so excited for you
another couple too Bo's excited he tried
to pour milk in my belly button
now we want to know what happens with
Kristen and Matt too yes and they
believe they very much wanted to share
their story to sport conversation too
yes thank you thank you thank you thank
you tomorrow our facing fertility series
follows the Journey of a woman who froze
her eggs when she was 33.
did your OB GYN ever talk to you about
the option of egg freezing or about
Family Planning at all no actually it's
always been interesting to me that they
don't talk to you about it in fact they
send you to a specialist
another important story she takes us
inside her egg freezing process tomorrow